we are on the cusp of fda approval for
coveted vaccines for young children and
at the same time the southern nevada
health district is striving to vaccinate
as many individuals as possible it
actually held a meeting on this today
bianca holman has a closer look at the
discussion with the holiday season
approaching an expected increase of
international visitors southern nevada
health district has a couple of irons in
the fire to combat kovid 19. here are
some of the highlights from that meeting
during the month of october the seven
day average a positive cases declined by
20 percent
most of those in the hospital or on
ventilators are unvaccinated and
breakthrough cases are still aware for
those who are vaccinated 96 out of every
10 000 people and this is information
provided by the health district about
160 cases to move into
moderate transmission which is below
50 cases per hundred thousand so we
still have a lot of work to do here
regardless the 293 cases is still not
near the record peak
recorded back in december where the
seven day average
was about two thousand cases a day
the cobit 19 task force is focused on
getting boosters to more people
especially those 65 and older and
there's another roll out of vaccine
incentives for the hard to reach groups
and finally plans are in place for
pop-up clinics to provide covet testing
and vaccinations at moore school once of
course that is approved by the cdc and
as of right now mass and social
distancing measures still in place we're
not at the point where we can relax
restrictions bianca holman live local
now